بالرغم من تضارب المعلومات الذي يطال
اعداد الشاحنات المستهدفه في البوكمال
ومحتواها لكن الاجماع يتمثل بضربه
اسرائيليه اخرى ساخنه لايران خلال اقل من
ثمان 48 ساعه حيث استهدف الطائرات مسيره
قافله شاحنات في منطقه واقعه تحت سيطره
الميليشيات الايرانيه في دير الزور شرقي
سوريا بعد عبورها من العراق ولم يتضح بعد
من يقف وراء هذا الهجوم العدد المرشع
المرجح للشاحنات المدمره هي ست شاحنات من
اصل 25 استهدفت بثلاث غراض بالمسيرات
والتي تقول مصادر سوريا انها اي الشاحنه
تحمل في الغالب اسلحه لامداد من الشياط
ايران كون تاثير الانفجار بعد الضربه كان
كبيره القافله كانت قادمه من ايران مرورا
بالعراق وبحمايه المليشيات المواليه
لايران كاحزب الله العراقيه وفقا للمصادر
السوريه وعند توجه تلك القافله الى سوريا
وعبورها
ميه الحدث الثوري وميليشيته هناك توقفت
الشاحنات في قريه الهري بالبكمال السوريه
وهناك تم استهدافها بالمسيرات واوضحت
المصادر ان الغاره الاولى كانت تحذيريه
لكن لم تصب اي شاحنه في ما استهدفت
الغارتان التاليتان تجمع تلك الشاحنات حيث
اصابت الصواريخ شاحنتين بشكل مباشر
واحترقت اربع شاحنات بشكل كامل وللتذكير
مشاهدينا معبر القائم يوصف بالممر
الايراني الذي يؤدي الى كل من لبنان
وسوريا يشهد كثافه عاليه بعمليات تهريب
الاسلحه وايضا البنيه التحذريه لانتاجها
وتجميعها على الاراضي اللبنانيه والسوريه
ورغم الاضرار التي لاحقت بمصارات الممر
الجويه والبريه هذه الضربات الجويه
المتكرره الا ان ايران لم تتخلى عنه
بتسهيل من ميليشيات الحجم وحزب الله
العراقيه منها العراقيه طبعا وعلى الجانب
السوري تس التغطيه عشرات من الشهاد
التابعه للحارس الثوري والتي تتخذ من
البكمال ودرزور مركزا لها
[موسيقى]